here at the Pete Home Show I'm sure
you've noticed we don't shy away from
course language what is this a Bible
study course language levity that was a
really inside Bible joke what I mean is
dirty jokes we have a lot of dirty jokes
on the show I love dirty jokes I love
swearing so to balance it out we thought
would help people out and give them
something for everybody with a new
segment we call nice boy telling nice
jokes
so my mom won't let me get a dog because
I'm allergic to walking it see that Pete
nice joke
everyone laughed no one's offended yeah
comedy it was good yeah just take notes
why did the hockey player become a
magician because he wanted to do a hat
trick
nailed it
that's how you do it
you tell a nice joke and people laugh
you ever talk about dicks and us all the
time like you Jesus Christ class it up
dude I got an a on my report card it was
part of the word fail but I still got it
clean classic that's how it's done okay
you think you can get away with saying
filthy [ __ ] just cuz you're [ __ ]
smiley all the time you're like let me
look at me
wieners balls balls it's not nice you're
[ __ ] deceitful Ref that's what you
used to be right you're thinking up all
right
here's an impression of my dad fixing
the car honey call the mechanic
and gold you're saying you're saying
don't interrupt me dangly Pig all right
dangly Pig you don't shut up I will cut
your throat like the pig you are okay
thanks guys I bid you adieu but I don't
know what that means
bye nice going nice look